the complainer in chief is at it again
despite gloating about getting quote
major things done joe biden continues
bellyaching about how the media covers
his disastrous presidency this in spite
of the fact that reporters sugarcoat
every one of his crises so much it's
like their willy wonka but that's not
enough for biden
there's a lot of major things we've done
but what we haven't done is we haven't
been able to communicate look how the
press is it has changed oh listen i i
get it i know you get you overstand it
you don't just understand you overstand
it
but here's the deal
one of the things is that it's very
difficult now
to have a
even
with notable exceptions even though
really good reporters they have to get
number clicks on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question
anyway it's just everything gets
gets sensationalized and weighs in but
i'm convinced we can get through this we
have to get through it
even democrats are getting fed up with
the president's inadequacies in office
one liberal strategist not holding back
with advice to biden telling the hill
quote it's really simple be the blanking
president
then it says discussion
but when you talk dirty
all right
what do you think of the fact greg that
he thinks that jimmy kimmel
not just understands but over stands
wasn't that clever oh that was so sweet
that he's going to use that for like a
month
and then he can then he'll just trail
off into some weird cloud of confusion
he has no right to complain the media
doesn't want to be critical of joe the
way they wanted to be critical of trump
it's just that joe was so unfathomably
incompetent they have no choice it's
like they had to be they had to be
dragged to the table to eat their
vegetables you imagine if joe had and
i've said this before i'll say it again
if joe had trump's media treatment he
wouldn't have lasted two weeks they
probably would have impeached him four
to five times you could have been
impeached over afghanistan if that was
trump
impeached over baby formula if that was
trump impeached over hunter biden if
that was hunter trump impeached over the
border crisis you could they would have
found an impeachment for every single
screw-up and then they moved on to
kambala if she were mike pence
all right geraldo the president's
numbers are lower than they've ever been
for the second time
so why does he think that the uh he's
done so many great things that are being
underexplained well he's actually uh
less popular than trump was at this
stage in his presence and i think that's
the first time that that has happened i
understand his frustration though gene i
i i i what has he done i i think that
when you look at the economy and i
understand gas prices i go back to it
because inflation is such a cancer
inflation is like if you were a
beautiful you had a beautiful body of
bodybuilder and you had cancer that's
what inflation is so that's the economy
and again we have inflation and it's
eating away at everything but he tries
he's trying to communicate he's uh he's
frustrated what is he communicating
everybody used to like him until he got
this job now nobody likes him so i
understand his frustration okay so go
ahead
just made the most ridiculous analogy
and this is coming from somebody about
the weightlifter ridiculous analogies
you have a bodybuilder with a perfect
physique who has cancer and joe biden is
calling the bodybuilder healthy
that's what the american people don't
like if you have cancer you're not
healthy so stop trying to say that
liberals fail judge and then they don't
blame their performance or their
policies they blame poor communications
but it's not their inability to
communicate it's the media's job to
communicate how great liberals are in a
much better way so
they end up fighting with the media and
the media
doesn't want that the media wants to be
on offense fighting against republicans
but now they're on defense against the
biden white house meanwhile the biden
white house is fighting amongst
themselves when they should just be
solving problems all we want are problem
solvers and that's what joe and the
white house don't understand i think my
analogy was great
all right dana dana the truth is that
you know biden may complain about the
media he may complain about their not
letting him out of the white house he he
just can't communicate or is it that
he's got nothing to communicate i
remember this one line from 43's book uh
decision points it was uh self-pity is a
pitiful characteristic and a leader and
you know being president is a
decision-making experience kimmel last
night said wow you have the worst job in
the world now that's actually that's the
best job in the world you wanted that
job you asked a country to get to vote
for you so that you could be the
decision maker one of their big problems
is that they will not be willing to
admit that the american rescue plan was
too big
and it fueled inflation and then they
added the infrastructure bill and
another trillion dollars and then they
wanted to do more
and now because they won't admit that
the only thing that they can do is say
well we have a communications problem do
you know what the easiest job in
washington a democratic communications
staffer the media writes the stories you
want to write they kill the stories you
want them to kill they make sure that
they show up to the events that you want
to show up at and they will be willing
to attack your opponents and say things
to them without even having any evidence
like crossfire hurricane if you look at
that
and that's the easiest job it gets the
democrats in trouble they need to stop
relying on the media they need to
actually think about what they could do
to earn good media it's not it's not it
shouldn't be given to you you have to
earn it is that what you mean by earned
media that is uh got it but you know
what when there's a sense of entitlement
i don't think they ever go back to
trying to earn it go ahead i just
noticed uh there's a typo that they
spelled weiner wrong
greg you're so
childish
squatters rights going to a whole new
level an outrageous story up next hi i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now